the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thursday and
house of the dragon video in this video
we will look ahead at next week's
episode by examining the new trailer
released by hbo this video gives us our
first look at the new episode it seems
episode 3 of house of the dragon is
roughly a year or a year and a half
ahead of the second episode not only are
viserys and allison now married but
they've also already had their first son
aegon of house targaryen
unfortunately for rhaenyra her own
half-brother aegon will be the roadblock
that is set in front of her and the iron
throne now before we go any further i
want to discuss the sponsor of this
video atlas vpn as i'm sure most of you
already know all of us are at risk of
having our identity stolen on a daily
basis as more and more of our
information and data goes onto the
internet what some of you might not know
is that one of the best ways from
stopping this from happening is by the
use of a vpn service this is something
that i've actually been using every day
for the last six months
well this month i've joined forces with
atlas vpn to bring you the most
affordable deal on online protection for
as little as one dollar and 83 cents
each month not to mention they also have
a 30-day money-back guarantee now other
than guarding your online identity atlas
vpn also blocks malware and malicious
links another thing it does is keep your
google searches private and even gives
you access to online shopping deals and
will notify you whenever someone is
trying to steal your identity one of my
favorite things about atlas vpn is it
also gives you access to other region's
content on the different streaming
services like netflix
for example if something is only
available in the uk all you have to do
is switch your ip address to gain access
to it in the us
right now atlas vpn is running a massive
discount to where you can actually get a
three-year subscription for only one
dollar and 83 cents a month and like i
said that has a 30 day money back
guarantee as well you can jump on that
deal right now before the time runs out
by going to the link in my description i
would recommend grabbing that deal now
once again i would like to thank atlas
vpn for sponsoring the video as i was
saying before the introduction of king
viserys targaryen's son will send shock
waves across the seven kingdoms now that
viserys finally has the sun he always
wanted many of the lords and ladies who
once swore fealty to rhaenyra will now
want aegon sitting on the iron throne
instead
she's about to find out firsthand just
how right rhaenys targaryen was there is
definitely some men who would rather see
the realm burn than to see a woman
sitting on the iron throne regardless if
king viserys does want rhaenyra to
remain as his heir this is exactly the
sort of dilemma we will see viserys have
to face head on now that he has a son
everyone will be in his ear wanting him
to name aegon as the new heir this
matter of succession will fracture many
other relationships within the red key
as you can imagine allison and
rhaenyra's relationship will never be
the same we can see that serato
hightower will make sure of this as well
in the new trailer we hear him say the
road ahead is uncertain but the end is
clear aegon will be king he's making it
known that he doesn't give a [ __ ] what
viserys thinks or wants he knows viserys
made rhaenyra his heir in fact it was
serato who was one of the loudest ones
in the room suggesting that vasera
should make rhaenyra his heir because he
was afraid the iron throne would go to
daemon now he wants aegon on the iron
throne because it would obviously
benefit him and his family the most as
always he's looking out for his own
investments now assuming house of the
dragon does follow fire and blood
viserys will have rhaenyra stay on as
his heir although everyone will be
whispering right over his shoulder
suggesting that he do otherwise this
will fracture the relationship of
viserys and serado the same as it will
rhaenara and alicence like i said in my
last video lines will begin to get drawn
in the sand as we see the greens and the
blacks set their sights on one another
we've also started to see the
disintegration of house targaryen's
relationship with house velaryon as we
have seen in the first and second
episode viserys hasn't listened to a
single thing lord corliss velaryon has
said in fact it is one of the main
reasons why he decided to go to the
stepstones without the king's blessing
this is obviously a relationship viserys
will have to fix
not only are the valerions incredibly
rich and influential but they also have
the largest fleet in westeros this is
someone he does need on his side
therefore viserys will most likely use
rhaenyra as a way to smooth things over
viserys will have his daughter mary
lorcorlos valerion's son lenore velaryon
although rhaenyra has no interest in him
whatsoever we hear rhaenyra say i do not
wish to get married but we also hear her
father snap back when he says even i do
not exist above tradition and duty
unfortunately for her this is something
she will be forced to do
neither one of them will be happy in
this relationship and as i've said
before
the marriage will be for alliances only
renera and lenore will have to look
elsewhere if they're wanting love
another thing we will see in the next
episode is the royal hunt we actually
saw robert baratheon go on one of these
and the first season of game of thrones
and like we saw with robert baratheon's
royal hunt they can be rather dangerous
it looks like rhaenyra might be attacked
by some animal during this episode we
see her savagely stabbing at something
this is most likely some animal she
encounters while they're out in the
woods i'm thinking that's why she has
blood all over her in this image we also
see vasara stabbing at something here
now what's interesting about this is not
only did robert baratheon die shortly
after he went hunting but so did viserys
targaryen's father balon we might
actually hear something about this in
the new episode
now the main event in this episode will
be the war for the stepstones something
they've been setting up since the very
first episode kraka strahar also known
as crack ass crab feeder is an admiral
from mir who serves under the triarchy
now it's said that the crab feeder will
lead armies and fleets and conquering
the stepstones from the island's pirates
and outlaws during this campaign he
earned his infamous nickname crack ass
crab feeder by ordering hundreds of
pirates staked out on the beaches to
drown in the rising tide
imagine just how horrific that would be
after the men are nailed to the stakes
as if that isn't bad enough they have to
sit there and watch as the water slowly
rises inch by inch until it inevitably
drowns them
other than maybe being burned alive
drowning would have to be one of the
worst ways to go lor corliss valerion
and daemon targaryen are now on their
way to wash out the crab feeder and his
men
in fire and blood the war for the
stepstones actually lasts for several
years and we might end up seeing more
than one battle in this first season
eventually daemon and lore corliss will
win enough of these battles that damon
will be named as the king of the narrow
sea we have seen him arrive back in
king's landing with the crown upon his
head now if you don't want to know how
these battles end i would stop the video
right here for those of you who are
interested in hearing what happens to
the crab feeder i will let you know now
daemon will eventually defeat him in
battle by removing his head with his
valerian steel sword dark sister i
really really hope they leave that in i
want to see damon hold this man's head
up high above his own he might want to
wear some gloves however because for
some reason it looks like the crab
feeder might have grayscale all over his
body now i'm not exactly sure what the
hell this is but it does look very
similar to what was all over the stone
men it looks like he has some sort of
flesh-eating disease unless the sea has
done something to his skin i guess we
will see if they made some of their own
additions to fire and blood i think this
season will only get more interesting
from here on out it's amazing that we're
already about to get some action and
only the third episode of the first
season if you remember in game of
thrones we didn't see any real action in
the first season there were a few
battles but all of them happened off
screen this episode will not only show
us a battle but a massive dragon battle
nonetheless we're definitely seeing the
benefits of having a giant budget with
house of the dragon now make sure you
stay tuned because things are only going
to get better as the season unfolds it
looks like the holding of hands is now
over rhaenyra and alicent will be out
for blood the only thing that now stands
in their way of the iron throne are each
other as always i want to thank everyone
for stopping by and watching my video i
hope all of you have a great day i will
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you